Speaker 1: The number of ways that the Republican
Party differs from the Democratic Party, numerous,
myriad ways, and I'm not just talking about
policy, I'm not talking about economic policies
that are vastly different relative to taxation
or just monetary policy in general.
I'm not talking about social issues and the
respect and regard we have for our fellow
human beings, the more humanist outlook.
I'm not talking about that right now.
I'm talking specifically about the manner
with which we hold our leaders accountable
or in in the in the way of the Republicans,
the manner in which they do not enter.
Andrew Cuomo, last week, Letitia James, the
New York state attorney general, concluded
a lengthy investigation into the behavior,
the conduct of Governor Andrew Cuomo.
And they found that he has acted inappropriately,
possibly criminally related to female staffers
that went beyond locker room talk, like Republicans
like to call it, he actually reached under
women's blouses and assaulted them.
Now aides are running for the hills, they
are quitting en masse.
He is a man unto himself.
He is an island unto himself.
He's losing support of longtime union leaders,
black political leaders in New York are abandoning
him.
He's toxic.
Even his brother is under fire.
Melissa DeRosa, this is from CNN, Cuomo top
aide Melissa DeRosa resigns as governor faces
potential impeachment.
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo is top aide
Melissa DeRosa, resigned late Sunday, less
than a week after the release of a report
from the state attorney general that found
Cuomo sexually harassed 11 women.
Quote, It has been the greatest honor of my
life to serve the people of New York for the
past 10 years.
New Yorkers resilience, strength and optimism
through the most difficult times has inspired
me every day, DeRosa, secretary to the governor,
said in a statement obtained by CNN.
Nancy Pelosi has called for his resignation.
Chuck Schumer, fellow New Yorker, has also
called not just them, though.
Here's Joe Biden when asked about it, also
saying he should resign
Speaker 5: a given back in March.
You said that if the investigation confirms
the allegations against Governor Cuomo, then
he should resign.
So will you now call on him to resign, given
the investigator said the 11 women were credible?
Speaker 1: I stand by that statement.
Speaker 5: Are you now calling on him to resign?
Yes.
And if he doesn't resign, do you believe he
should be impeached and removed from office?
Speaker 6: Mistake with the timing.
I think he should resign.
I understand that the state legislature may
decide to impeach.
I don't know that for a fact, I've not read
all that data
Speaker 5: and he's using a photo of you embracing
him in his self to say that these are commonplace
kind of embraces that he made and the allegations
against him.
Do you condone that?
Speaker 1: Look, I'm not going to flyspecked
this.
Speaker 6: I'm sure there are some embraces
that were totally innocent.
But apparently the attorney general decided
there were things that weren't
Speaker 1: so at this point, impeachment proceedings
seem unavoidable.
Karl, he is the state the speaker of the New
York State Assembly, and they have initiated
an investigation, impeachment inquiry.
If I may, if I'm a betting man, sometimes
I am, I would say that it is, as I just mentioned,
it's unavoidable.
It's going to happen and he will be removed.
There's actually been sheriff's offices contacted
or at least one where there very well could
be criminal charges brought against current
still Governor Andrew Cuomo.
Here's here's Carl Hastey discussing the matter
at a press conference
Speaker 7: he has completed.
The assembly is working to expeditiously conclude
our investigation, which covers a broad range
of issues so that we can bring this sad chapter
of our state's history to a conclusion.
As I stated last week, the governor has clearly
lost the confidence of the majority members
of the New York State Assembly.
The attorney general's report lays out in
painful detail the many instances in ways
in which he reportedly harassed and created
a hostile work environment for the employees
of the executive chamber and others he came
in contact with.
I'm heartbroken.
Let me be clear.
No one should have to endure the type of behavior
detailed in the attorney general's report.
We had a historic moment in our state's modern
history for the first time in more than 100
years.
The assembly is undertaking an impeachment
investigation of a sitting governor chairman
leaving the members of the Judiciary Committee.
And my majority colleagues understand the
gravity of the situation that we find ourselves
in today.
Future generations will look to us and how
we conducted ourselves in this moment in order
to ensure due process, which is embedded in
our system, we vacc for all evidence, unredacted
and unfiltered, used by the attorney general's
investigators to reach their conclusion.
The process to begin receiving that information
did not begin until Saturday evening.
We have not yet received all of it.
We seen a lot, but not all of it.
We've also asked the governor to submit any
relevant evidence he may have by Friday, August
13th.
Our goal is now to bring this matter to a
conclusion with all due haste, no pun intended,
the Judiciary Committee has made progress
on the issues they have been investigating
and to provide an update on those issues on
schedule and the progress of the overall investigation.
I will now turn to the chair of our Judiciary
Committee, Charles Levine.
Speaker 1: Now, this is in stark contrast
to how Republicans fail to hold their own
accountable.
We witnessed Marjorie Taylor Green.
Zain, abhorrent, racist, xenophobic things.
And being able to keep her committees, if
it were up to Republicans, it was Democrats
who had to take it upon themselves to vote
her off of her committees she went onto to
say nonsense and then apologize about comparing
the masks to the Holocaust, you may remember,
and then gave a little press conference.
I just learned about the Holocaust.
Nonsense, Matt Gates.
He's in hot water for unspeakable crimes.
And still nothing.
He still sits on the Judiciary Committee,
Donald Trump, the twice impeached.
President twice acquitted by Republicans,
clear crimes.
Clear outlining of obstruction of justice
in the Molalla report, nothing.
Incited and attempted overthrow of the United
States government and an attempted overturning
of a free and fair election through means
not just violent insurrection, but also using
the mechanism, the wheels and gears of government
that were at his disposal by using the DOJ
as a cudgel.
To attempt his insurrection.
The the just say it was fraudulent and I'll
take care of the rest.
And how do Republicans hold themselves accountable
if they don't?
Here's Chuck Grassley, the venerable octogenarian
who worked.
He was he was the senator when I worked for
the Senate many years ago.
He's been there forever.
This is him waxing excuse making about why
Donald Trump had every right to try to subvert
the Constitution and attempt to overthrow
the government.
Watch this, as he would call it, cockamamie
reasoning.
Speaker 7: The president has every right to
discuss ideas and strategies with his closest
advisers.
The president, whether that president is Democrat
or Republican, should feel unrestrained to
bring ideas to his closest staff for robust
discussion.
Eventually, the facts will come out and Trump
will have to address them, good or bad, depending
on the facts at hand.
However, the essential question that should
be asked, what was the final decision?
And that is my major concern about the recent
public comments coming out of these interviews
I've discussed relating to this new Trump
investigation.
Unlike my Democratic colleagues, I won't discuss
the evidence publicly at this point in time.
But let me remind the American public with
a couple already public points, did Trump
fire Acting Attorney General Jeffrey Rosen?
No, he did not fire it.
Speaker 1: So Donald Trump, according to Chuck
Grassley.
Has every right to counsel to gather his his
sage advisors.
Chuck Grassley is acting as though Donald
Trump making excuses, acting as though Donald
Trump was just he's just floating ideas as
though he's talking about welfare reform or
tax reform or the the never ending infrastructure
week.
A president of the United States who has raised
his right hand and swore to uphold the Constitution,
to faithfully execute his duties and support
and defend the Constitution against all enemies,
foreign and domestic, does not.
Get to foment revolution.
Does not get to encourage and incite a frothing,
violent mob to insurrection to construct a
Gallow, a hangman's Gallow.
On the on the on the lawn of the Capitol while
chanting Hang Mike Pence.
No, Senator Grassley, that is not how this
works to coin a commercial, and that's not
how any of this works in the